now we're resuming our study of certain
Kierkegaard's work philosophical
fragments and today we're going to be
looking at three sections chapters two
and three and then this will interlude
the titles of appendix yeah each one of
them has title that tells you a little
bit about what's going on in the section
a lot of these things are interweaving
but they're also being worked out in
detail there so chapter two is called
the goddess teacher and Savior and when
he's saying thy God rather than just God
think of it is in terms of philosopher
trying to approach the notion that
historically have been sort of placed in
a lapse by the various revealed
religions of God so if your guard is
thinking about how the divine has
manifested itself what we can know about
it what we can think about what it would
have sort of pushed onto us to consider
at different times without necessarily
assuming a commitment to institutional
Christianity as such that that could
come later on chapter three is called
the natural paradox that's really in
some ways the central concept the text
itself not just sort of a revelation
that's taking place through through
teaching in Chapter two and also to
wrestle work but the fact that God God's
relation to us even what we are as
created beings is paradoxical and that
this doesn't mean that reason stops up
short
surely as a lot of people that would
think about paradoxes the paradox is not
irrational it's in some way is super
irrational that's its and not just above
reason in the sense that okay here's the
paradox reason bumps up against it they
can never go any further if reason and
rationality is to penetrate into the
paradox to some degree to some extent it
has to do so by becoming more flexible
more fluid more adequate to to its job
to understand its to making sense of
things
now that's difficult for reason it's
difficult for human rationality to do
that but we'll talk about that a little
bit more later then in the appendix to
Chapter three so it's really you know
carrying out that model to further the
paradox and offended consciousness how
does the paradox manifest itself to the
human being to the rational human being
of thinking things out Kierkegaard has
this concept of offense and that is the
central way in which the paradox is
engaged with and grasped as such by the
unity through the offended consciousness
so we're going to look at each of those
in turn let's start with the God he has
his teacher and Savior which mean
subtitles an essay of the imagination
and it starts out talking about Socrates
again so I think it's it's useful to go
back to this is opposition between
Socrates as a teacher and God as a
teacher that we outlined in the last
lecture looking at the very first parts
of this work and
these are not the only possible ways to
understand education but for Kierkegaard
an education not just in the sense of
one can get in a degree getting a
certificate making it through certain
courses Thanks
but education in the sense of really
introducing a person bringing them into
study of what is the most valuable what
is most real what what is and where one
is going one's destiny these are the two
primary types or forms or structures of
Education that character guard is
interested in thinking about and if you
think about a Socrates what what are the
Keats firms are the key concepts that
you can associate with a platonic or
Socratic way of educating well Socrates
doesn't make a claim to have the truth
within him and to their their more
communicated to the other person and
spending talks about himself as being a
midwife the truth is actually within
each one of us available to us through
recollection because there's metaphysics
having at one time or another then these
these disembodied souls who saw these
things who encountered these things and
new realities and such at that time and
then forgotten and then now that's being
you know really woken in us you don't
necessarily have to be committed to that
particular metaphysics in order to have
a sense of knowledge as being something
like recollection and if you have an
idea that there is within us something
that's part of our nature
not yet explicit but they're available
already there in its full form ready to
be brought to life and it just requires
the most restrictive way barriers or
to sort of you know coverings or
whatever it is maybe some sort of
ascetic process may be some sort of
dialectical process then you've got
something with the Socratic method of
Education I was in the thing Kurt in a
lot of respects is his likeness you know
the ideas that were born with are
they're sort of submerged in our
consciousness which is like this giant
thesaurus or treasure house or storeroom
and we just have to awaken these ideas
to bring them to life I would say there
are many other types of views of
Education that see things like this and
if this is the case like he said
Socrates is a teacher he's not a teacher
by just directly communicating
information from his full mind to the
learners empty mind he is trying to
bring the learner out of their own state
of ignorance and to find the knowledge
that's been concealed below but the
knowledge is there doesn't have to be
woven in
implanted or anything like that so he
says one would get Socrates he says this
was indeed a Socratic understanding the
teacher stands in a reciprocal relation
in that life and it's circumstances
constitute an occasion for him to become
a teacher while he in turn gives
occasion for others to learn something
so why is Socrates st. teaching the
young men of Athens
well this Socrates is older Socrates in
his turn was taught by older people who
did the same sort of intellectual
midwifery with him like do anima does in
symposium and they sort of help him to
bring these these thoughts of his mind
is like he will do with the young man
theaetetus
he will do unsuccessfully with some
other people like Alec Li's or Romina so
he gives occasion for others to learn
something he embodies it as a attitude
an equal proportion character Garrett
says of the autopathic of the
sympathetic such also was the Socratic
understanding and hence T would accept
neither grazed or hunters or money for
his instruction but passed judgment with
the incorrupt ability under this
departed spirit why didn't i produce me
- why did he make money why did he take
money because he didn't feel that he was
actually giving something all he was
doing was again clearing things away so
that the learner could learn what was
already within them but the truth so he
asks you know this is a this is our
teenage witches in an age that's
positive understand it's positive
Socrates is negative
any talks about Socrates being rooted in
a zeal for what is you
human and a discipline of self marked by
the same divine jealousy as is
discipline well there's a co discipline
through which he loved the divine as
between man and animal hair relationship
is possible the disciple gives occasion
for the teacher to understand himself
and the teacher gives occasion for the
disciple understand this term
understanding is going to be
particularly important in these these
three chapters it's not just
understanding oneself it's understanding
the other who is another human being so
the teacher and the learner originally
it looks like they're at this
disposition but what's actually
happening is the learner is being
brought up where they want to be to the
level of the teacher and now there's
reciprocal understanding between the two
of them they are both the same just in
you know these concrete circumstances
and these concrete circumstances which
are different from each other but
essentially the same that is the
Socratic position now Kierkegaard that
talks about the guy and he says it
doesn't work this way in the
relationship between the god this
teacher
and the human being has learned it says
the God needs no disciple to help him
understand himself nor can they be so
determined by any occasion that there's
as much significance in the occasion as
the resolve God doesn't need anything
from us if there isn't if there's a
divine if there is a God then it's not
as if he needs us somewhere along the
way to make sense of the things for him
for him
call God
Socrates learn something of himself and
of the truth in his dialectical
engagement with other people and other
people learning the process as well
the God doesn't work so there's none
there's not that motivation there that
Socrates does yeah you're at the dance
what could move him to make us
appearance he must indeed moved himself
and continued to exemplify what
Aristotle says of him in Aries it says I
can eat dosa Ponte Connect which is the
the unmoved thing which moves everything
else there are some that this notion of
God is being done over that finds its
way into arguments about God's existence
and about God's nature later on now
Kierkegaard is uh if he moves himself it
follows he is not moved by some need as
if he could not endure the strain of
silence but had to break out of the
speech but if he moves himself but is
not what I need
what else can fulfill so this is a good
place to that's applause the thing about
this if there is a God and God is going
to reveal something is going to open
something up is going to interact in
some way with human beings as learners
what would move him to act in that way
what we want to do anything personal
what moves him to create what moves him
to sustain everything in existence is it
because God has to well then he's not
really God right because
something over him like you know the
Greek idea of fate or or some sort of
ideal which would compel God to do that
sort of thing
and if God didn't do it and I suppose
you get in trouble you know what else
well that doesn't work because then the
greater thing you got Denny and then you
actually have something very much like
like certain Gnostic cosmologies just
got to eat something does the greater
need something from the lesser does that
make sense the greater than sort of in
thrall to the lesser they're right not
perfect not great or does God have to in
order to be God necessarily lose himself
or give himself to existence to create
to form a world to connect up with
rational beings it seemed to be Hegel's
field but Hegel actually depicts God he
has in certain respects being motivated
by desire
well this is sort of on the right track
Kierkegaard says what could motivate God
love that's the only thing and not love
as desired not love as errors a lack
which is directed towards that of which
it is the lack if I love
a lot of sense a particularly woman by a
desire to have that woman and to make it
not necessarily to have sex with her
that's it he won't be next to her to
have her in my life as ession so to
speak maybe just the possession of my
eyes my ears it's not that sort of life
so it's it's love in a different sense
he says love finds its satisfaction
within and not without his resolve which
stands of no evil reciprocal relation to
the occasion must be from eternity this
is another interesting aspect let's say
you had somebody who had this kind of
infinite love this creative love that
was not merely born of desire or
familiarity or something like that
truly I got a soft giving how that
manifests itself is that something that
manifests itself through all of eternity
we're talking about this is romantic
things doing eternity eternity to be
really rewarding the place or in kind
if the love turns out not to be exactly
what you you thought it was because if
you have an eternity you're plum in
every single possible little nook cranny
corner of that love and if it doesn't
actually measure up to the infinite look
out you're going to be bored you're
going to be upset and you're going to be
resentful I don't think that the vision
that we put forth and some of our
romantic
tragedies dramas that sort of stuff
wherever people can be immortal and
being long-term gravity isn't
necessarily what we what we would think
it would be might actually turn out to
be a horror but what about true full
entire perfectly that would have to
manifest itself over an eternity and
unfortunately God is eternal right
so God would manifest over over eternity
so God is saying eternally loving all of
creation all the way down to the
littlest thing you know the sparrow was
fall he knows the individual hairs on
your head and all these these sorts of
things God is in love so to speak with
every single particle of the cosmos is
there something missing there Jake
regret thinks there it is he says his
resolve which stands have no equal
reciprocal relation an occasion must be
from eternity though when realized in
time it constitutes precisely the moment
this is what we've been talking about
before the eternal intrudes itself into
time this is part of Kierkegaard's
metaphysics is this is Christian
metaphysics in general that the infinite
the eternal can actually and some may be
brought in relation to that with witches
simple so he says for when the occasion
the occasion corresponding are
commensurable
as the answer of the desert with the
private books at the moment doesn't
appear it's only when something ruptures
the day-to-day experience when something
doesn't fit all the need to packaged
systematized concepts that we actually
have a moment so he says let's go back
to this now moved by law of the gods
thus eternally resolves to reveal
himself but as long as the motive so
love must also be the end for a movie a
contradiction for the Guyana motive and
an evolution that correspond his love is
a love of the learner has Amos to win
here Curtis only in love with the
unequal can be made equal and it is only
in equality or unity that an
understanding can be effected and
without a perfect understanding the
teacher is not the God unless the
obstacle comes wholly from the side of
the learner he's refusing to realize
that which has been made possible for
him we have a lot rolled into this this
short passage here so let me recap moved
by love God's eternally resolved to
reveal himself reveal upsell to who to
the learner to the human being but as
love as the motive love must also be
begun love is motivating God to do what
he wants what God wants to do is
actually to reveal to the learner what
love is and to attract the learner
thereby and actually to make the learner
loving his love is a love of the learner
and his aim is to win him it's only love
Kierkegaard says that can take the
unequal and equalize them place them on
the same level thought I can't do that
desired by itself can't do that reason
can't do that reason can do it a sort of
way where lowers everything's the same
but that's not
they only love can take the unequal and
actually make it become truly equal it's
only an equality or unity that an
understanding can be the effective and
God wants an understanding with not just
desire not just devotion God wants the
human being the learner to actually know
to understand this is something I think
very important to realize about
Kierkegaard's work parent is walking
framed as if he's and here rationalists
as if he you know has this leap of faith
where you've got reason and
understanding and thinking over here and
that's you know what makes us
essentially what we are or maybe
philosophers and then there's this
massive leap over here to the world of
faith you know some sort of imaginary
lala land where you know who knows what
happens other than you know stuff that's
in the Bible and that would be totally
irrational that would have no connection
over here that would not fulfill us as
the kind of beings which we are rational
beings
that's not Kierkegaard's position
Kierkegaard's position is actually that
this love of God enables us as rational
beings to be fully what we are to need
to be fully rational to understand
you're only truly rational if you
actually reason about if you actually
grasp but you actually engage everything
that there is if you're covering stuff
up because you don't want to talk about
it or because it doesn't fit into your
system you're irrational you make it
reasonable and rational on some level
but you're interactional a higher more
importantly so back to this now
Kierkegaard says that this love that God
has is through through
Hannity for how great is the difference
between the amazing the small banner for
the god to make himself understood but
this is not so easy of accomplishment if
he's to refrain from annihilating him
like this that existed it says let's not
joke to quit quickly to a conclusion at
this point let's think about this a bit
let me give you a map similarly and he's
talking about different kinds of unhappy
lovers so he says much as her in the
world of unhappy love and we all know
what this means the lovers are prevented
from realizing their union the clause is
being Benny it varies there's another
Kingdom unhappy love for which there's
no perfect birthday parallel he'll talk
about this as something that we can
imagine but even our imagination of it
is just merely an account and this is
actually worth thinking about when it
comes to religious language talking
about the divine
how do we actually speak about something
which is infinite which is eternal which
goes beyond what it is that we go well
we can use the conceptions experiences
and words language of the world and then
we can say well God is kind of like this
so for example if we want to say God is
is a father and we're all his children
traditional religious view of things not
just many many others as well what we're
doing is we're looking at fatherhood and
the father a child relation and the
world as we experience that this economy
we understand this perfectly
now over here God is this like that but
you know it's some other kind of win8
some metaphorical way and if that's the
case that our understanding this is
always a bit more murky a bit here a bit
less reliable when it comes down to it
that what we know over here and if you
think about the the arguments for God's
existence than ever that are given
throughout the history of philosophy you
think about them not so much in terms of
God's existence but think about them in
terms of God's nature this is a lot of
the process we go from what we know in
the world and then we reason to God by
analogy we have words and language and
terminology that makes sense to us in
the world that we apply that to God
before God is like a warrior you know if
we talk about God's arm smiting we're
using pictorial images which clearly
don't apply to what the images impassive
and acts from eternity and is
incorporated incorporeal
doesn't have any arms or anything like
that if that makes the understanding is
on this side could there be some things
where
away where our understanding of things
is in some ways limited not just because
we're imperfect because we have to be no
limits at one time or anything like that
but just by being human beings by being
what we are
by not being infinite might not be a
eternal in the same way that God is
eternal could there be cases where
what's going on in the mind is more real
in some ways more intelligible and in
return the concepts that we have to make
sense of it are mere shadows our images
are less we are less apt that would be a
very platonic way of thinking about
things actually you know it's not just
they sort of you know Jewish or
Christian or Muslim or you know view of
things it's also a platonic or the ample
time to do things that that sees things
that way but Kierkegaard is saying this
about love she's saying that when it
comes to love we have conceptions of if
we get experiences of it and what we
have in the world over here when we make
sense of and what we have language for
if we apply it to God because fully made
perfect sense think of the metaphor the
biblical metaphor that was Laughton used
and then was transferred into other
things
relationship you know I'm supposed to be
a loving relationship originally between
Israel and God this really acts like a
harlot and goes a lot from screws around
and you know comes back to God every
once in a while what it needs something
and then goes off you know find somebody
else to fool around with and that's if
you look at the book of Hosea that ends
up being sort of master of metaphor for
things and the main character himself is
actually in a relationship like that as
well
so it's being mirrored on all these
different levels and the idea is well
the relationship to God or with God or
from God is like that in some sense
well again do we fully understand the
entire meaning of marriage or is if we
start doing this kind of
analogizing is there something of this
and that trumps what's on this that is
greater that makes deeper sense well
that's what he's talking about here so
he says much is heard of the world but
I'm having love and we all know what
this means
the lovers are prevented from realizing
their union the clauses being many and
various there's another kind of any
happy love for which there's no perfect
earthly
but we can try the gesture yeah this is
the sort of thing we're talking about
here and this comes not with the
inability of the plumbers to realize
their union to get together to be
together to live together to the United
but rather from their inability to
understand one another it says this
brief is infinitely more profound than
they haven't which meant in common they
speak since it strikes at the very heart
of one and wounds for eternity it's not
external its internal that's deeper it
wounds not just for a period of time
before an eternity to be misunderstood
is to be miserable in many ways so he
says this infinitely deeper greed is
essentially the prerogative apologies
superior since only he likewise
understands the misunderstanding that's
important the superior is able to
understand then this understanding that
takes place between the two the one
who's below the inferior is the one who
does misunderstanding things and there
can be certain situations in which it
becomes impossible to make oneself
understood to the other person this is
why I mention they're moving towards
talking about the fence when somebody
has become offended I think we've all
had this experience somebody becomes
offended yeah
every heaven that you try to make to
remedy things to explain why it is that
their feelings
block two to explain why you did what
you did while you couldn't help doing
that sort of thing everything needed to
of that sort only makes them more angry
or miserable or hurt usually all three
of these things all about them together
because they are passions which are
interconnected that anything like that
that you do accentuates the degree of
misunderstanding and the person who
actually has a better vantage point who
can see what's going on they become
unhappy they feel miserable as a result
of not being able to get through to the
person whether they're trying to reach
perhaps you can lovingly only to have it
thrown in their face or rejected or you
have some give an explanation you have a
person to pick on that one single thing
and ignore everything else that you said
that is to be in what regards calling to
reach here and who is in grief here God
as the teacher so he gives an analogy
here he's a beautiful little story he
says suppose there was a king who loved
a humble maiden so we have a
asymmetrical relationship there's the
king who loves a humble man and this
king like it says the part of the king
was not polluted by the wisdom that has
loudly enough real thing he knew nothing
of the difficulties that the
understanding discovers in order to
ensnare the heart which keep the poet so
busy it was easy to realize his purpose
every statesman fear of his wrath every
foreign state tremble before his power
no courtier groveling in the dust
dear-dear
moon Deimos
have any crushed so I had this great
king I won't marry her I will you know
take this
this humble maiden who is beneath me and
status you know the gender things that
are bothering you here switch and round
Queen humble man right that's not the
real issue the real issue is the
asymmetric ality of us so the king is in
love with the maiden and like it says
love is in Sultan's but have unites
peoples but it is triumphant when it
makes that which was unequal equal in
love so this sounds like you know it'd
be great if it be the King better than
another person of his reign and they get
together in all your festivities and
great things come with that it's even
better when the King elevates somebody
else and creates an equality where there
was any quality before but the King as
Kierkegaard says hasn't anxious thought
who but a king of things kingly thoughts
was thought he didn't tell anybody about
him
what does his anxious [ __ ] would she be
happy in life at his side would she be
happy with the situation would she be
able to summon confidence enough never
to remember what the King wished only to
forget then he was king of Qi have been
a whole maybe if this memory word
awakened in her soul and sometimes like
a favorite lovers steal her thoughts
away from the king luring her
reflections into the seclusion of a
secret greed for you know somebody does
something for you somebody makes you
better than you are raises you to the to
a status that
don't actually deserve do you feel bad
if you actually have a noble heart if in
fact you have a good conscience your
conscience will be troubled by that if
you have a badly formed conscious
conscience then perhaps you won't be
bothered by it you know sort of taken
for granted again this is what I deserve
if that's the case then you doubly don't
deserve to be raised under only though
the one who could actually see the
goodness involved the magnificence the
generosity could have any measure of
deserved for being raised up to that
level so this is made of his that sort
and that he is worried
what could the different options be
perhaps the Maidan would be intend to
become as not she recognizes everything
that I have everything that I become is
from you is a gift is something that
I've not particularly in myself
deserving of but will accept and be
grateful for does the will go back to
the teacher and learner does the teacher
give and the learner just faces
themselves that's not really work why
not
well like he says this could not satisfy
the king precisely because he loved her
and because it was harder for him to be
her benefactor than to lose her
in order to prove for that to occur
though being misunderstanding and
attempted understand attempt to say I
get it I'm going to do this I'm going to
make this PETA my response yeah it's the
best response I think it would still be
a misunderstanding because the God wants
the king wants the subject which is
originally lower to be brought up to
that level and not to like for sink back
down to and say I'm not worthy like it
says the moment to stare decisis
significance the learner is an error
that by reason of his own wheels
and yet he is the object of the God's
love and the God desires to teach him
this concern to bring into equality with
himself if this equality cannot be
established the God's love becomes
unhappy so you know with this parallel
if the God teaches the learner and
elevates the learner and learner then
says I am I am is nothing I realized you
know things better than all I did
nothing I'm not worthy of you in a way
that's the right response that are
waiting on a deeper level is the wrong
response it makes the gun and it's
interesting here Kierkegaard there's
something that he's saying here that
this very good fun I think and at which
we often lose assignment particularly in
philosophical traditions of Christianity
says men sometimes think that this meant
a manner indifference of the God since
he doesn't stand in need of alert
God doesn't mean anything from anybody
including the people that he's he is
venturing into this
the teacher and learner but in this we
forgive or rather last we prove how far
we are from understanding till we forget
that the God loves the learner and just
as that keenly grief of which we have
spoken and we found only a kingly soul
and has not even been in the language of
the multitude of men so the entire human
language is so selfish it refuses even
to suspect the existence of such a
creature this is exactly that dynamics I
was talking about before where our whole
language because our language is derived
from the things in the world is not the
language that we would actually need in
order to speak of the infant infinitude
and even the love and its different
aspects of God for that reason he says
God has reserved into himself this
unfathomable grief what are the lines of
that grief you know we you might say
well that's the case you know we can't
know anything we better just shut up
yeah well you can't know it for sure if
our very language by which we're trying
to make sense of this is already sort of
you know finite worldly then we can't
possibly know about this it's
unfathomable unfathomable grief well no
we can just you're headed to a certain
extent the Kierkegaard does that he says
to know that he may repel the learner
that he does not mean him the learner
has brought destruction upon himself a
its own guilt
he can leave the learner to his own fate
to know also how well nigh impossible it
is to keep the learners courage and
confidence alive without which the
proposed understanding and equality will
fail that alone will become nothing
happy this is the bit that got
interested to every single soul through
which God attempts to be the teacher and
to do so it loved the risk that it will
be sterile scandalized stifled that this
unfathomable Greek will be video what
are some other possibilities well here's
another possibility regret says the
union might be brought about by the
elevation of the learner the God would
then take him up into himself
transfigured him to fill this
comfortable buddy will joys and when the
learner forget the misunderstanding and
tumultuous joy so God would take the
human being the learner who is down here
or stuck in his own stuff mainly because
of the very fact that he has managed to
misunderstand in relationship with God
and what God is is what love is about
how and Godman is elevate the sort of
yell hocus pocus dominocus fix
everything
you know trance transform that person's
nature if we want to think in terms of
original sin God wipes it all out God
doesn't just you know forgive original
sin well allowing the effects to still
remain God says all right brand-new
stuff everything well the Kierkegaard
says the learner might be greatly
employment for I'd such happiness is
this how wonderful something to find his
fortune made like the home made because
the I have now have
how wonderful also his helper taking
this in vain to see by heart with this
work in a certain way
check regret doesn't say this one but
they think of it is common to take me
and I'm a pretty screwed up human being
many many different ways there's a whole
history there and different parts of my
screwed up this screwed up the screwed
up machinist or or fallenness whatever
concept you want to use karyotypes by
the fastest time spot a sin they're all
interconnected with each other the worse
of each other there are some ways which
have made some progress but a lot if God
were to suddenly wipe all that would be
left there would be some things left so
I'm not all you know hollowness and
privation start with swear sugar gliders
would that be the same thing as allowing
me to understand what took place just
wiping it all out
would that be the same thing as
redeeming too bad whitening it all
surely removing all the balance or you
can pop to the surface
it wouldn't no way out of your lesson
plan God doesn't want that God wants all
the guys to love with what's not a
possibility the union might be brought
about by the God showing himself a
learner and receiving his worship
causing him to forget himself over the
divine apparition so in this case the
God doesn't transfer
the person who bring them up higher
doctor shows up haha the person is at
all events and hollows it's amazing is
wonderful
and they give worship like he says the
key might have shown themselves humble
made it on the top of his power making
her forget about forgetting herself and
worshipful admiration but that is work
it's really addressing this might have
satisfied the native but it could not
satisfy the king he says so it comes to
the teacher of the learner God could
actually satisfy us the learners in that
way by and some ways making us forget
the entire situation teaching and
learning making us forget ourselves and
who marks on this earth a lot of Mystics
want to lose themselves in God and they
think that that's what God wants if your
birthright
but those mystics would actually be born
if your parents right that those mystics
would be asking God to essentially face
their own consciousness and just fill
them with God so that's all that they
can see if God doesn't want them why not
well Kierkegaard says the King desires
not his glorification but hers if God is
truly loving you the way that God is God
does not want our worship because God
needs anything and God does not want our
worship just because God wants to sort
of fill us up in here who we are as
individuals as human beings be gone and
just be replaced by a little kind of God
or something
you know mirrors of God would be a very
narcissistic get that with it in some
ways the Mystics God God wants again to
bring us up to God's on the level
because God loves us insofar as they
can't get them God's love is unhandy she
says if the moment is to have decisive
significance again this is going back to
the issue of the risk how unspeakable
will be the gods anxiety so not only has
got to have a brief God actually has
anxiety over what will happen as God
tries to bring her up to his own level
so the Union he says must therefore be
brought about in some other way so let's
think about Socrates again rebel is left
once again that recall Socrates for what
was the Socratic ignorance if not an
expression for his love of the learner
and it's an equality with them to admit
your own ignorance that's a trick you
know say I'm not going to try to push my
own BS on to you my own cat formed
opinions is to show love or the other
person and that makes perfect sense when
you don't know the answers when you
actually are not fully informed when you
don't understand everything but if you
actually do understand when God because
the teacher he says his love cannot be
merely seconding in assisting like
Socrates you know stripping away the
ignorance obstacles that sort of thing
but it's creative God love is creative
God's teaching is creative giving a new
being to the learner or as we have
called them with a man
so biblical theological way of looking
at things a philosophical way of looking
at things which are two sides of the
same coin
then they says by which designation we
signify the transition from non-being to
being so being born anew being born
again that sense of just having a
religious conversion and going around
and getting baptized that sort of thing
but in a more fundamental ontological
sense theologically is the
correspondence of going from non-being
to being or the non being that is one
when one thinks one actually has the
plug to the VA to true me actually being
what you are
so he says the truth is that the learner
was the teacher of everything this is
what makes it so difficult to affect an
understanding the learner becomes as
nothing that yet is not destroyed that
he comes to owe everything to the
teacher and yet retains his confidence
that he understands the truth and yet
that the truth makes him free that he
never gives the guilt of its only error
and yet this confidence Rises victorious
from the truth between man and man Terry
Grant says the Socratic midwifery is the
highest relation and beginning is
reserved from the God whose love is
created and I'm barely in the sense
which Socrates so beautifully expounds
but what is that sense well you know
there's there's the form of good out
there or beauty and it sort of begets
things in us through us and those are
those are themselves beautiful things
the Christian view of things where the
revealed religion view of things goes
beyond the Socratic house oh well
for Socrates the highest relation
between Manny Mattos midwife relation
nothing is the form of the good and the
form of the good you know if you're good
enough if you actually devote yourself
to philosophy and like flame you had a
new baguette good things and you as a
response but it's really sort of some of
you acting so much as wasn't good at the
agency and that's what that's a riots
the symposium frames things in terms of
a ladder or in terms of set of stages
moving from the beautiful body to
beautiful bodies from beautiful bodies
to beautiful souls from beautiful souls
to the virtues themselves that make the
soul beautiful beautiful virtues the you
know orderings or laws that make those
happen all the way up to this one good
how does it work in in Christianity
particular it says since we follow the
union could not be brought about by an
elevation must be attempted by a descent
let the learner behaves in this act we
include the lowliest not just the
philosopher not just intellectual not
just a great soul or the beautiful soul
everyone says the God must therefore
become the equal of such a one and he
will appear in the likeness of the
humblest what's the humblest though the
humblest is one who must serve other to
the God of their work
with servants now we've got started
taking on the disguise the way that
certain there was a Christian heretical
dosages that said you know Jesus
generally taking on flesh that that was
just appearance don't get this comes
from oh sorry
he and could that be the case no because
if God doesn't mean to do it God's been
good whole walk because God loved God is
actually going to become a servant it
will become as he sensed his true form
and figure this is the unfathomable
unfathomable nature of love desires
equality with the beloved not ingest
merely but an harassment in truth so God
becomes a certain that Kierkegaard said
something really interesting here to
sustain the heavens of the earth by the
Fiat is an impotent word so if this word
were withdrawn for the fraction of a
second the universe would be plunged
into chaos
now that's you know pretty big stuff
right you're not I'm not capable of that
but hopefully is there you know needs
God God is there to do that but he says
how many tasks compared with be
remembered
I may take offense what has been
constrained by love to become its Savior
he's saying all this metaphysical stuff
great metaphysical stuff that that God
does is really nothing compared to the
act of love becoming weak becoming a
servant taking on suffered death
humiliation out of love to win back
those who don't even really want to be
won back those who think that they're in
the right and God and he says this is
really interesting every other form of
Revelation would be a deception the eyes
of love either the learner but he has to
be changed when the fact that sealed for
him that this is necessary why doesn't
that happen as he says love does not
alter the beloved it alters itself so
it's one option or there would be
permitted to prevail in frivolous
ignorance of the fact that the entire
relationship was a delusion this is the
error term incentive pagans every other
form of Revelation would be a deception
from the standpoint of the Divine Love
so God has to reveal himself as the
teacher as a saviour in the form of the
suffering servant Pepperell straight
away to teach isn't it
maybe this is what struck people so much
that they don't gossip us about a new
genre of literature that they engaged in
ceremonies to reenact that reenact parts
that there
the stories that correlated it back to
other things they wrote letters about
now here we're actually going to finish
I notice we haven't actually gotten to
the chapter three and the acoustic
illusion that I promised we will get to
those in a future video because it's
this turns out to be so rich in debts
that this hour period I want to devote
to us at this point Kierkegaard accuses
himself of engaging and wretched
plagiarism and this is one of the most
interesting portions or features of this
work that I've been showing throughout
all this time and this before he puts in
the mouth of sort of an imaginary reader
a set of insults or the torch which is
to say you're not telling us anything
new beginners a matter of fact you're
just sort of taking old stuff and
gusting it up and giving it a new face
and I don't see you doing anything
productive anything that's that's really
changing the game here he chooses a lot
of players so this poem of yours is the
most wretched abuse of plagiarism ever
perpetuated but it's neither work nor or
less than what every child knows so this
is everybody knows this this is story
out here and he says wonderful stretches
up this is response every going to steal
steals from some other poet it in so far
we are equally religion my thought is
perhaps less harmful because it's so
easy for you to figure out where it came
from
I'm not claiming that this is anything
new that this is a radically new
doctrine in her story or advance I
already said nobody gets PS Socrates
except you know through God as that as
the teacher oh my god I'm just you know
Kassem stuff so he says maybe this poem
is like a proverb for which no author
can be assigned maybe mankind is the
author of ban tagger the author of this
poem then everybody gets to claim it and
then you know he has his interlocutors
say no that's not be installed and then
Kierkegaard responds ah now I understand
you it's from this reason you called
white procedure the most wretched act of
placing because I have not still for any
individual Norfolk grace of God where he
hasn't where soul that got away and
though I'm only an individual beyond
blacks implicitly pretended to it to be
anything I'm speaking in in place for
further using the language using the
concepts that the guy has given sort of
penetrating into God's own mind and
attributing to God anxiety grief log of
a sort that goes beyond what we've
experienced the world how can i how
could I do that
well what would take him to be a
plagiarist I it would take that God had
actually done that that God actually did
have those things he says it surely
would have been strange for this to be
the human production at my heart it's
not impossible but I've heard of mansion
national vehicle to God or to magical
God evil man but not to imagine that the
God would make himself into the likeness
of man what I'm going to leave a lot of
us is is this insight that the very
notion that God loves in such a way as
to want us to
to try to reach out to us without being
motivated by desire and need by
familiarity any other forms of law but
you know from them from experience in
the world they had itself as a
revelation that itself is something
coming in from outside or from above our
reason and our experience of the world
and changing things showing us a new way
showing us a new experience showing us
something that we can then afterwards
start to wrap our head around but we
couldn't imagine it by ourselves we
couldn't make it up by ourselves we
couldn't reason our range to it and have
it come from something beyond major the
supernatural to God and so before this
reason he said we stand here before the
miracle what is the greatest miracle for
Kierkegaard it is God revealing to us
not only myself all Huzoor something
like that but love a love which goes
beyond the concepts that we previously
had of what love could be a lot of that
extends the range of possibilities of us
that extends the range of our
imagination so here it is the same yeah
okay I am plagiarizing but what I'm
Fletcher Isaac is actually coming from
God so that's where we'll leave off a
next video we will try to get into the
paradox the offense
solution